[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON ADERS: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for having me here.
I just want to
say, first of all,
I'm truly honored to be here.
This is really cool to talk to
so many awesome, smart people
and to be the company that I've
watched, you know, as a fan
almost my whole adult life.
So I just really appreciate it.
My name is Aaron Aders.
I'm the founder of
LEIF Technologies.
And I'm absolutely
obsessed with snowboarding.
There is just something
about that movement
and that feeling of snowboarding
that's just incredible.
And it's so incredible that
you've got 39 million people
around the world spending
$2 billion a year
to enjoy it for only five
days a year on average,
just five days a year.
Like would you play
basketball five days a year,
or soccer, or anything else
for just five days a year?
Maybe, but with snowboarding,
it really is that incredible.
It's that worth it.
But, obviously, we
have-- a lot of the year,
we're on the sidelines
just hanging out.
Now, I know a lot of you
might not be snowboarders.
So what I'm about
to show you, you
might not grasp
the full reality,
the full gravity of that.
So if you could just, for a
moment, think about something
that is an activity that you
can only enjoy five days a year.
Maybe it's traveling,
like a fishing trip maybe
or climbing a mountain.
Think about-- think
about that experience
for a second and those feelings
that you have enjoying this.
And, now, imagine
if somebody told you
you can enjoy this experience
and have these feelings
on demand anywhere in the world,
after work, on the weekends,
whenever you want.
That's basically what we've
done for snowboarders.
And so what is it
about snowboarding
that makes it so incredible?
And it's a combination of
speed, and turning, and carving,
which is leaning
into your carves--
your turns rather.
But it's this controlled
drift, I think,
that is really that
addicting part.
And the drift, it's
something that, you know,
from the first time you ran and
slid across your kitchen floor,
or drifted out the
back tire of your bike
or your scooter as a
kid, or doing donuts
around your high
school parking lot,
there's something just
addicting about that.
And snowboarding is
really unique because it--
it takes that drift and
puts you in total control,
and so you can spin,
and you can slide.
And there's really just
nothing else like it.
And so that is just so unique
to snowboarding and something
that has just never
existed anywhere else.
Another great thing
about snowboarding
is that community aspect,
so sharing this adrenaline
with your friends and going
out and snowboarding with them.
And sometimes, you know, given
that snowboarding is just
a five-day-a-year experience,
you might only see these
friends five days a
year or, at least,
just enjoying this experience
with them for only five days.
And so all of these
things together,
snowboarding can be a little
bit of a frustrating sport
most of the year.
And so that's what
we set out to change.
And we are a group
of snowboarders
that all share that dream
of riding all year around.
And I can tell you
getting to that point
where we can enjoy the sport
all year round as a snowboarder,
it really is a dream come true.
And so what does it look like?
It's kind of hard to
describe in words,
somebody actually snowboarding
in Dubai or around the world.
So I'll just show you a quick
video that'll show the--
the capabilities of the LEIF.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So there's a lot going on there.
But, essentially, you can
just think of the LEIF
that we've taken the
mechanics of snowboarding
and traded the potential energy
that a mountain gives you,
mountain slope, and for the
electronic mechanical energy
of electronic motors.
And so really the key
secret sauce to our system
is this 360 drive
that you see here.
So this is really
a caster wheel just
like you see on the bottom of
the shopping cart with a motor
strapped to it and transmitting
energy through a slip ring,
and going into a battery pack,
and controlled by your hand.
And so those drive
wheels, the base of it,
are a little bit
lower to the ground.
And you can see in the
tilting and drifting
part the outer edge wheels, they
function just like a snowboard,
so the edges on your snowboard.
And that's really there for
just steering, and control,
and braking.
And the rest is you.
Your whole body controls
this crazy experience just
like a snowboard.
And it's really almost magical.
If you know how to
snowboard, and you
take all of those, that muscle
memory, and that experience,
and you jump on the Leaf, and
you can channel that through,
it just works.
In fact, it only works if you
ride it just like a snowboard.
So
How do you stop?
Very important question.
You stop just like a snowboard,
so sliding on your edge wheels
just like you slide on
the edge of a snowboard.
It's the most fun and most
effective way of stopping.
You can go from our top
speed of 23 miles an hour
to a dead stop in less
than two car lengths, which
if you try that on a
bike or something else,
you might, you know,
go over the handlebars,
but you're leaning into that--
that slide and that force.
So you can stop really hard
and be really comfortable.
So it gives you a lot of control
when you're at top speed.
And you might have noticed there
is these hooks that kind of fit
over your feet.
And this adds a ton of
control, just like a snowboard.
Now with a snowboard, you're
locked on, and so you can't--
there's no safety bailout
for the snowboard.
But you have snow
under you, so it's OK.
But when you're
operating over pavement,
you definitely want to have
the ability to jump off,
and it's funny,
once you-- once you
get rolling on the
LEIF for a while,
and you go back to
snowboarding, you're
kind of weirdly freaked out by
the ability you can't jump off.
So it kind of takes a couple
of rounds to get back into it.
But that's a key
feature and a must
for getting out these footholds.
And so on the acceleration,
it's a wireless remote control.
And so you can think of
this as kind of controlling
your mountain slope.
And so if you have it
all the way forward,
the gas pedal completely
hammered down,
that's like a triple black
diamond, like, dropping in,
just getting off super fast.
Or you can just really lightly
move the controller forward,
and it can be like a
nice bunny hill slope.
But the nice thing is, is
that at any point in time
if you get nervous, if you get
a little bit out of control,
you can let go, and the motors
will just coast and eventually
will come to a stop.
And so, really, it's a
bit like snowboarding,
but you can make the mountain
go away any time you want.
And then we made the battery
swappable, because if you're
a snowboarder, even
if you've never
dreamed about snowboarding
on city streets,
you've definitely dreamed
about the endless slope
because at some point, you get
to the bottom of the mountain,
which is a total drag because
you have to wait in line,
get in a lift up,
and so you always
dream about that endless slope.
And we wanted that ability.
And so for us the
endless slope is
getting to the end of
a battery, not having
to go home and charge it,
but rather just switch out
another battery and keep going.
These batteries will go up to
15 miles on our largest size,
and so far, I
haven't seen anybody
go past three batteries.
That's been kind of the human
limit of fun at this point.
Yeah, so before I get into
this part, this project,
I mean, from the beginning,
I mean, the crux of this
was figuring out that
powered cast reel.
That was the thing that
electronic engineers,
mechanical engineers, investors,
friends and family all told
us was probably impossible.
But none of us are engineers.
So we didn't have that
experience to kind of think
it was impossible.
We just knew this had to happen.
We just knew that if we could
bring this experience to 365
days a year, the
idea is just so big
and such a big life
improvement for snowboarders.
And so we just--
we-- they didn't understand
we had to make it happen.
And so we had to kind of go the
bootstrapping route, especially
since we didn't have
a lot of funding.
And, again, you know, when
we were pitching investors
in the beginning trying to
convince them to snowboard
everywhere, they just--
nobody would believe.
Even Kickstarter didn't
believe, in fact.
When we launched
our Kickstarter,
they flagged us for spam because
they thought it was fake.
And, luckily, I-- I was--
we built this in Brooklyn.
Kickstarter is in Brooklyn.
So when I got that email,
I was pretty annoyed
because it was real.
And so we just
grabbed the board,
rode over to Kickstarter's
headquarters,
and just did laps in their
lobby until they launched
our campaign, which
only took about an hour,
but he got up and
were up and running.
But there were a number of
lessons that we learned along
the way because when
we-- we started this,
it was kind of early, and a lot
of harder projects happening
now, but--
but a few years ago, it
was kind of desperate,
and there wasn't like a tutorial
out there, even a roadmap,
on how to bootstrap hardware.
But we learned-- we
were able to do it,
and we learned a lot
of lessons on the way,
so I'll share those with you.
Number one, YouTube
is the Matrix.
And what I mean by that is my
favorite part of "The Matrix"
wasn't like dodging
bullets or flying.
It was like downloading skills
to your brain instantly.
That was what I was
most fascinated about.
If I could take anything
from "The Matrix"
and put it in real life,
that's why I would pick.
And that's what
YouTube is in a way.
I mean, I'm not an engineer.
I knew nothing about what we--
all this technology that we had
to put together for this board,
and I remember it was like one
lazy Thanksgiving afternoon.
Everybody had eaten.
We were just kind of
all laying around.
And I thought, wow,
I'd really rather
be snowboarding right now.
And I had an electric
skateboard at the time.
And I was thinking,
like, this would just
be such a better experience
if it felt like snowboarding.
It would be game changing.
And so I started kind of
thinking about those pieces
of my electric skateboard.
And I started searching,
OK, lithium ion batteries
was a big feature.
I knew nothing.
What is a lithium ion battery?
And I found on YouTube a
lecture from Carnegie Mellon,
90 minutes, about lithium
ion battery technology.
And that was four years ago.
We've actually gone through
a lot, built this product.
I know maybe 5% more than I
did that day after watching
that lecture, and, you
know, I watched it,
and as like, kind of like, you
know, unplugged the Matrix,
and I was like, I know
lithium ion batteries.
And then I was
like, OK, how do I--
how do I go to the next piece?
How do you put electricity
through a rotating circuit?
And turns out there's these
things called slip rings that I
didn't even know
about, and they're
in everything, a headphone
jack, in fact, is a slip ring.
And so I saw a few
videos on those.
And we kind of had to reinvent
the slip ring a little bit,
but the main idea was there.
I knew, OK, we've--
there's got to be a slip ring.
There's got to be
electronic batteries.
There's got to be motors and--
you know, in a lazy afternoon,
you can surprisingly
get a lot done on
YouTube if you spin
it the right way, of course.
But my biggest, I guess,
advice to even engineers
is, if you don't know
anything about the technology,
there's probably a
YouTube video out there.
And, you know, even
if it's some guy
in his garage
putting a tutorial,
sometimes those
are the best ones.
Next we-- kind of came up
with a way of doing PR,
and we called it
downstairs demo.
And so traditionally
with PR, it's
a big part of
bootstrapping something
because you don't
have an ad budget,
and you probably can't
even hire a PR agent.
And so you've got
to get, you know,
organic articles out there
that you aren't paying for.
And, traditionally,
you know, you--
you research the writers
that you think you can--
that would be interested
in what you're doing.
You look at their interests,
the topics that they like,
and how you can
position your company.
And you write an
awesome email that you
send at 10:00 AM on Tuesday
to kind of catch them
in between tasks.
But the problem is, everybody's
doing that, you know?
They're getting thousands of
emails at 10 AM on Tuesday.
And, unfortunately, most
likely, it won't get read.
And so you have to take
it a step further in what
we call the downstairs demo.
And the first step
to that is find out
where they work, the
address to where they work.
This is getting
creepy, but just hang
in there with me for a second.
So you find out where they work,
and you show up maybe an hour
before or after lunch, maybe
the last hour of the day,
and you get up to their lobby.
You're not going to get past
the lobby, but don't worry,
you don't have to
get past the lobby.
You just take your
smartphone, and you
film yourself using your
device in their lobby
or in front of their building if
they kick you out of the lobby
or on the street if
they make you get off
the foyer, which has happened.
And in our case, you know,
just doing donuts and saying,
hey, look, you're one
short elevator ride
away from trying
this crazy new tech.
That got a 100% response rate.
Not everybody came down, but
half the people came down,
and all those people
wrote about it.
So that's how we
got in "The Verge,"
"Engadget," "Gizmodo," and
a lot of big publications.
The other half of
the people all said
the exact same
thing, which is, hey,
I've been burned by hardware
startup Kickstarter projects
before.
And I just can't
write about you.
If you can figure that
out before you show up
to their lobby,
that would be great.
But, you know, sometimes
you just have to show up.
But that's a big thing.
I mean, we were lucky
we were in New York.
And it was convenient,
but when we did this,
we did it in one to two days.
And so quick trip to New
York, or LA, or wherever,
if you're not in these areas,
you can get a lot done.
OK, so on the
prototyping side, you're
going to need a 3D printer if
you're prototyping hardware
because rapid
prototyping is just--
it's not rapid.
You know, you're talking
one to-- you know,
one to three days on the
fastest turnaround time,
and it's incredibly expensive.
In fact, on the first,
you know, two models,
you might send a
rapid prototyping,
you could actually
buy a 3D printer.
And once you make
that $1,000 to $3,000
investment for a 3D
printer, it's almost free,
and you can obviously
iterate your prototypes
a lot faster by
printing them at home
because you are--
you have become
essentially a rapid prototyper.
But there's ways to even
speed it up beyond that.
So, for example, say you've
got a small motor mount
that's part of your
project, and you've
got eight features
that, you know,
holes, or things that
fit into other things
as part of your project.
And you have to dial
in each one at a time.
Now, say this a little
motor mount out only
takes an hour to print, which
is a pretty fast print, OK?
You've got eight features,
each one, we'll say,
takes two or three, kind
of prints to get it right.
That's 20 prints you
have to make to dial in
that one motor mount.
Now, that's still light speed
compared to rapid prototyping.
You won't even get an email back
from the company in 20 hours.
But you can go way faster.
And that is by printing
in 2D rather than 3D.
And so if you've got that
that motor mount, and you're
trying to dial in a
hole, you can actually
just print a 1 millimeter
layer face and, you know,
peel it off, get your calipers
out, measure it, dial it in.
And you can print
that 1 millimeter
layer in two minutes.
So 20 prints
instead of 20 hours,
you just turn it into
40 minutes of printing.
And that's how you can dial in
entire parts of an afternoon.
And that was a big,
big lesson kind
of we learned along
that way, and, you know,
it took literally days to kind
of get all this stuff together
and be on the road.
Definitely iterate with
off-the-shelf components,
and this isn't
anything, a new idea,
but you definitely have to
kind of think about some
of the constraints
that might come
with those off-the-shelf
components.
And we had to deal
with one in particular
that was a little scary.
So our first version
of this, we basically
took apart an
electronic helicopter,
put the motors on a
shopping cart wheel,
and put that onto a skateboard.
And we were off and running.
And what we didn't
realize, though,
is a feature of electronic
helicopters, which
is great when you're flying.
If you lose radio signal,
it'll go full speed
to stay in the air.
I think you guys understand
where I'm going with this.
We'd be riding around,
and in New York City,
maybe the most dense place
of 2.5 gigahertz networks,
and when you lose
signal, you go full speed
for a good like
one to two seconds
until it kind of gets back.
So it was kind of
this mechanical bull
that you had to be just ready
to go full speed at any given
time.
And so we kind of learned with
these parts, OK, you know,
we learned these constraints.
And so a lot
off-the-shelf parts,
you kind of have to read a
lot more of the directions
than you might be prepared
to before you get going.
Then the mobile lab, so you
definitely with hardware,
you're going to be doing
a lot of field testing.
And in the beginning,
you're going
to be doing a lot more
fixing than actually testing
in the field, and those
minutes that turn into hours,
and eventually turn
into days of testing,
they're like gold
in the beginning,
and, you know, when you're
out in the field and something
breaks, which in the beginning,
will happen in the first two
minutes, you know,
you don't want
to have to go back
to the office,
you know, 45-minute train
ride, and go fix it, and then
go back out to the field.
You need to take your
mobile lab with you.
And so, obviously, there's
like a lot of mechanical things
that are built for going with
you like electronic drills,
wrenches, things like that.
But eventually, you know,
you're going to have to solder,
and soldering
irons unfortunately
take a lot of current because
they have to get really hot,
and you won't always
have a plug with you,
especially if you're, you know,
going on New York City testing
your product.
So you have to find plugs
around, but they exist.
You know, we've soldered
outside a public bathroom
in Central Park.
I've soldered in a coat
closet at the Plaza Hotel.
They're nice enough to let
me get in there and solder.
They have these random plugs
in the ceilings in the subway
that you can-- you
can dial into and get
enough current to solder.
But just bring the whole
lab with you, like,
don't think you have to go
back and just, you know,
carry everything around.
If you've got to drag
a wagon with you,
it's really worth it
because, again, it's
going to be two
minutes of testing
and two hours of fixing
in the beginning.
And, so, you know, I could go on
and on about hardware stories,
startups.
But I think maybe this is a
good time to just switch it over
to a Q&A and, again, I
just really appreciate
everybody coming out to hear
our story and the invitation.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Now we have a question cube.
Anybody?
OK, I am going to try to--
awesome.
AUDIENCE: Nicely done.
So the big difference
I see in terms
of between this and
boring skateboarding
is the terrible things
you're doing to the wheels.
So you said that people go
through three batteries, which
then you have to take
home and recharge.
How often do they have
to replace the wheels?
AARON ADERS: Really
good question.
So in skateboarding,
you have a couple
of factors that go
into your wheels.
One is kind of rebound,
how bouncy it is.
Another one is called durometer,
which is how hard it is.
And so they have durometer from,
like, you know, like, jelly,
all the way to hard plastic.
And the skateboard wheels
fall somewhere in between.
And so the harder
durometer will last longer
because it just resists that--
that abrasion a
little bit better.
And, also, it slides
better because it's not
gripping that pavement.
And so we use a bit harder
durometer wheels than probably
the average skateboard.
A skateboarder would consider
our wheels a bit hard
on that durometer side.
But, again, it kind of
works with that sliding,
and it lasts a lot longer.
And, also, a key, so you
can tell a little bit
in this image.
So the outside of the wheels
are kind of getting dirty,
and they start to cone.
And so whenever you
get too much wear,
you just flip the
wheel 180 degrees.
And then you start
working on the other side.
And then you flip it again,
and you flip it again,
and you might get
six flips before you
have to change the wheels.
When I had-- it was a
five mile round-m trip
commute in Brooklyn, a set of
wheels, when flipped regularly,
would last about six months.
AUDIENCE: On this?
AARON ADERS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wow!
AARON ADERS: But when
you're commuting,
you're not, obviously, doing
a bunch of 360s and things.
You know, you've
got a place to be.
SO--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but even so--
AARON ADERS: But even
so, yeah, you can--
you can make a set of wheels
last a very long time.
AUDIENCE: So when you say you're
going with a harder material,
what's the--
what kind of snow skiing
does this correspond to?
Is it like a prepared piste or
morning somewhat frozen over,
or just the skid-- the
braking performance
you had look pretty good.
So it feels-- it looks like and
feels like a pretty soft snow.
AARON ADERS: Yeah, I would
say the-- in the most ideal
scenario, which is a nice,
kind of broken-in wheel,
and super smooth--
it's really the
pavement actually
that kind of determines the
feeling more than anything.
If you're on like
a garage floor,
say, like, a really slick
concrete, it's not like ice,
but it's definitely like a
really hard packed, we'll say.
But the best is kind of
a nice kind of blacktop,
like a fresh street.
That just feels
like a nice groomer,
like you got the first
groomer run of the day,
and you're just--
just jetting super fast.
I'd say it's kind
of more like that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AARON ADERS: Nice.
AUDIENCE: This is
really awesome.
Can you talk a little
bit more about how
you, like, eject from the board
or how the straps come off?
Like, can you adjust the--
the degree to which
you're strapped in?
And then like how
does the trigger work?
I noticed two buttons
in your video.
AARON ADERS: Yeah,
so straps first.
We-- where did we go?
OK, here we go.
So Chris actually did that.
And I told him, I
said, OK, you're
going to have to catch a
front edge and bail out,
which if you do this on
a snowboard, there's no--
there's no turning back.
I mean, you're going
to go face down.
So we probably should
have this in slow mo.
But more or less,
when you're to get out
and eject really easily, you--
the footholds are kind
of out from the edge.
So when you're riding, you're
putting outward pressure
with your feet to really, like,
hold in and kind of maintain
that position.
But to get out, you just
bring your feet together.
And if you bring
your feet together,
you can even jump forward.
But if you don't, you know, you
can jump backwards or whatever.
But, yeah, we're
kind of trained,
and you get a muscle
memory after doing
it a couple of times
and just, like,
hopping together
and getting out.
And you can adjust the
height, and how tight it
is, and things like that.
So you-- I ride a
little bit looser
because I like to be able
to jump out very easily.
But you want that control.
You want to be
able to really like
press in because
that's really going
to give you that broad control.
On the remote control, so there
is a trigger and a thumb wheel.
And that's really--
you can find that
on most wireless, remote
electronic ridables
because there's the safety
or dead man switch, which
in our case, is the trigger.
And then there's
the thumb wheel,
which is the accelerator.
And there's kind of
two schools of thought,
and the skateboarding,
or electric skateboarding
community, is kind of
split down the middle.
And it's just whether you
have the deadman switch
on your thumb or
your forefinger,
and you have the accelerator on
your thumb or the forefinger.
So the other way of doing it
is putting the deadman's switch
on your thumb, and then the
trigger kind of like, you know,
the old little RC cars.
The reason we didn't go
that route is because we do
find that some people, when
they crash, they grip, you know?
And you definitely don't
want to go full speed.
And so, even in our
case, if you grip,
you're not going to, you know,
likely move the thumb wheel
forward.
But moving the
thumb wheel backward
will actually provide electronic
braking, which, typically, we
only use if you're in
like a tight space,
and you can't turn
sideways to brake.
But the sliding
the brake, I mean,
that's the most fun,
the most effective,
and it actually got us
about less than half
the product insurance rate as
a normal electric skateboard
because with those brakes,
they're all electronic.
And, you know, you
can lose your brakes
by losing the wireless
signal, breaking a belt,
or going over 25 miles
an hour, at which there's
too much momentum to stop you.
And so that provides a lot
of stability and safety.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
And I have actually like dreamed
about snowboarding to work,
and snowboarding on
roads, and stuff.
AARON ADERS: Yeah, it's here.
AUDIENCE: If you could
talk a little bit
about your background,
what you were
doing before you started this?
AARON ADERS: Sure.
I actually-- I co-founded
a marketing agency
with a couple of buddies
when I was 24 years old.
And it was doing a lot
of digital marketing,
a lot of SEO, so
Google was obviously
very relevant to our daily
lives in that agency.
And, you know, but I'm
a lifelong snowboarder.
This is something, you know,
that I always dreamed of.
I actually had started a
version of that company
when I was in high school,
and my junior year, I actually
moved out of my parents'
house and started
just snowballing all the
time and barely graduated,
but it was always--
kind of my dream--
my dream thing because I'm
from Indiana originally.
And it's super flat, but
there's a lot of snow.
And I would only get
to ride once a year.
And so dreaming about that
at the end of every snowboard
trip, just-- it's always been
kind of in the back of my head.
But, yeah, I had
a background of,
you know, starting
a company before.
And so when-- on
that Thanksgiving
Day when this thing got in my
head, it just couldn't get out.
And so, eventually, when LEIF
started growing and needing
more of my time, I switched
over full time from my agency
to LEIF Tech.
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell a bit how do you
see the evolvement of
that, the next model,
or the next generation, how do
you see this product going even
further?
AARON ADERS: Yeah, for sure.
I think that lithium
ion battery technology
is going to define a
lot of the direction
because we've really nailed
the experience in terms
of that snowboarding
feeling, and I
think that future
products from us will--
will maybe get a little
bit more dialed in on that.
I mean, that feature
is really nice,
but I think it's more
about just being lighter,
possibly being faster,
but really just--
and getting the price down,
I think, could help a bit.
And that'll come with
volume as we grow.
But, you know,
just really serving
these 39 million snowboarders
around the world.
That's our dream is just
to grow our beloved sport
and make it a year-round
type initiative.
AUDIENCE: You just
led into the question
I've been holding back.
So with a skateboard,
I can see a point
with putting the battery
pack on the board
because you
routinely do actually
take your feet off the board.
But with this, when you're
traveling strapped in,
you've got much less
reason to keep your--
keep the battery
back on the board.
So you could wear
it, and you just
mentioned that the
board is heavy.
Are you implying that the
board with all the stuff on it
is heavier than a
snowboard and a pair
of depressingly-heavy boots?
AARON ADERS: Well,
actually it's about equal
because you have so much gear
on when you're snowboarding.
So if you threw, you know, your
boots, your jacket, your pants,
gloves, and all these things
in a pile with your snowboard,
it's about the same weight.
And so, you know, we're
still talking 15, 16 pounds
on our smallest model.
But, you know, I mean, the
dream is to go even lighter.
If you're not living in
New York, or San Francisco,
you're probably not walking
a lot with the board.
So it's not really an
issue for most people
to just throw it in
the back of their car.
But we definitely
want it to be lighter.
I mean, that's just probably a
better experience all around.
And, you know, I do believe
that, you know, one day,
you'll buy a cell phone
with all the energy
I'll ever need for it.
And so hopefully that
will happen at the same--
with our board as well.
AUDIENCE: So I think the
design of your straps
is really interesting, and I was
wondering if you've explored--
so I-- I have one of those
surf-style skateboards with
the--
I don't know if you've seen
these where the front trucks
really turn a lot?
AARON ADERS: Yeah, it's got
a caster wheel, it kind of,
well--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that--
AARON ADERS: Yeah,
it pivots, right.
AUDIENCE: That kind of thing.
It's made by a company,
a local company,
called Carver, the
one that I have.
And I-- and I love it,
but you can't easily
ali with that skateboard because
it's a little bit unstable.
It occurs to me
that, like, if I had
straps kind of like your straps,
I could probably jump up curbs
without a problem with
that, and it might
be an interesting thing to try.
I don't know.
When you were
prototyping this stuff,
did you try it on-- on some more
standard kind of skateboards?
AARON ADERS: Well, they're
a bit scary on a skateboard.
And I'll tell you.
One, it's kind of hard to
push and then get back in.
But the second thing is, I
mean, you can't slide and stop.
So you really, really, really
don't want to be locked in.
I mean, that's why
with the skateboard,
the electric skateboard has to
be completely clean on the top
so you can, you know, kind
of move around and get
your stance, but
for us, you know,
you're really fixed
on the outside.
And so that ability to
slide to stop, I mean,
that's what the footholds
really help you with.
But on a skateboard, again,
if you're not pushing,
then you don't have to
worry about moving back in
to push so if you
have electronic.
But, again, like, it's a
little scary just because you
can't-- you can't
slide and stop.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Yeah, the thing about
pushing is, like,
with those special trucks
that I was talking about--
AARON ADERS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can--
you can basically--
you barely need to push.
You can just go side
to side and carve.
AARON ADERS: Oh,
the pumping, right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and pump.
But, yeah, I get the--
AARON ADERS: It's the
stopping part that's scary.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AARON ADERS: How do
you stop on this thing?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I guess,
sometimes you can jump off.
You can do a power
slide type thing,
depending on your wheels.
AARON ADERS: Yeah, maybe
if you got over that--
that caster, and
maybe you were able
slide and get a
little friction maybe.
But, yeah, I find them scary
on almost anything else.
But, yeah, we have tried that.
You definitely want to
be able to turn and stop.
AUDIENCE: Has anyone
ever done anything
that you weren't expecting
them to do with the board?
AARON ADERS: Well, I
think that, you know,
the hardest part of this
project wasn't getting
the thing invented, actually.
We did that in about five
months from just an empty desk
with drawings to,
actually, a thing
on the ground that, you know,
you could slide stuff down.
The hard part was
getting it to something
that a consumer is not going to
break in the first 10 minutes.
Yeah, I mean, I
think consumers will
do like things with
your product that you
wouldn't imagine, you know,
sitting on the motherboard,
for example.
But I think some of the
more surprising thing
was just kind of how
quickly a lot of people
have picked it up.
You know, I think,
in my case, it
was a little different because
I was riding prototypes.
I would brake constantly.
So it kind of took
me forever to learn.
But seeing how quickly
people jump on and just start
sliding around, I mean, just
blows my mind sometimes.
I'm like, wow it took me
hours to get to that point.
And they literally just
kind of jumped off.
But the key thing was dialing
in the snowboard feel.
And so if you
snowboard, we actually
have you close your eyes
when we put you on the board
for the first time, and
we control the speed,
and you know, we let you--
we hold the shoulder so you
have a little bit of stability.
But if you close your eyes, and
you imagine you're on the snow,
it just happens
immediately, just magically.
But then when you open
your eyes, and you--
you know, you see the pavement
and all these other things
that kind of make you
nervous, then, you know, you--
you've got to kind of
learn to get over that.
But what we learned from
doing a lot of demos
is, if someone has snowboarding
experience, just blindfold
them, make them close
their eyes, do something,
because then they'll feel
that in the first 10 seconds.
And once they feel that slide--
because it really does feel
like snow because you're
kind of going
sideways, and like,
that just doesn't
happen anywhere else,
then they're hooked.
Then they will go through
and fall or do anything
to kind of have
that feeling again.
And so that was a big thing
we learned going on is,
like, get a user sliding
as quickly as possible.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying that
it's pretty easy to learn if I
don't-- know how to snowboard,
but I don't know how
to skateboard?
AARON ADERS: You're
actually better off.
In fact, the best candidate that
we could ask for that has never
got on a board
before is somebody
that has never skateboarded
because there's
certain things you have to
unlearn from skateboarding.
If you ride this like a
skateboard, it just won't work.
You'll be super
frustrated, somebody
with snowboarding experience,
obviously, but also a surfer.
So if you can surf
and snowboard,
you'll pick it up pretty
quickly because surfing, I mean,
you learn that middle balance
point because, you know,
learning to surf, it feels
like you're-- you're on ice.
It's just crazy.
But you really learn to
kind of balance over.
And that's a key
thing in the beginning
because when we start
people on the board,
we don't put them under the
footholds in the beginning
because, you know, they've
got to kind of learn
how to bail off.
And so without those footholds
to pull the board around,
you really have to maintain
that center balance.
And we find that surfers
do really well with that.
So, like, people from Brazil
just jump on the board,
and they're just like gone.
They pick it up really quickly.
AUDIENCE: How much
is this board?
AARON ADERS: So the 10-mile
model starts at $1,549,
and, hopefully, if you're
watching this video,
in a few years, it's a lot less.
AUDIENCE: OK, and
then last question,
so I remember a while
ago I saw this--
I don't know if
this-- maybe this
is the same company, Freebord?
AARON ADERS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Basically,
it looks like--
kind of looks like this
just without the motor.
AARON ADERS: Yeah,
so, really, I mean,
we definitely invented a
few things along the way.
But, I mean, at a high level,
we just took existing tech
and just put it in, combined
it in different ways.
So the Freebord
plus the Boosted,
you can kind of think of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because I
remember thinking like at that,
like, oh, I wish it would
just go and flatten.
So--
AARON ADERS: Yeah, no, when I
saw that for the first time,
it was like, I've never
had a religious experience,
but when I saw that,
it was like, it just--
it was incredible.
But then I did some
research, and, well, you
have to have a hill, and
I was living in Manhattan,
and there's like no hills.
I was even going to buy just
[INAUDIBLE] in a parking
garage.
But as a skateboarder,
I know you
get kicked out of parking
garages, like, instantly.
So I was kind of
back to square one,
but, you know, Boosted came out.
And they were the first to use
the AC motors, these really
tiny motors.
And I got one, and I was like,
OK, I think it's possible now.
But, again, that-- you know,
strapping it to a caster wheel,
no one thought that was
possible, absolutely
zero, nobody.
AUDIENCE: So do you think people
can use this to like train
for snowboarding?
Like someone who
wants a snowboard
but doesn't know
how to do it yet?
AARON ADERS: Yeah,
so we definitely--
we want to be the gateway
drug to snowboarding,
you know, for people in
areas that don't have snow.
And I love so
snowboarding so much.
And I just respect the sport
so much that, you know,
when we launched,
I felt inherently
that this could
make people better.
But I didn't want to
make that claim up front,
saying this is going to make
you a better snowboarder.
But that is the
feedback we're getting
from our customers, especially
people that have only
been a couple times, and
they're really new to the sport,
and they get the LEIF, and,
you know, one of my favorites
was a customer we
have in Singapore
that he'd been on
a couple trips,
was just obsessed with
the sport, got our board.
He went he went on
a snowboarding trip
with some buddies,
meanwhile, bought our board,
and he got back to Singapore,
rode his board for three weeks,
went on another snowboarding
trip with the same buddies,
and they all were, like,
you just had a whole season.
What happened?
Like, you got way better.
And that's the thing.
I mean, when you're
snowboarding,
when you take into account lift
lines, and lifts, and lunch,
and, you know, the
first day, you're
going to be smoked in the
first couple of hours.
You might only have of
like real actual riding,
you know, just a
few hours a day.
And so, you know, if you
can get out with the LEIF
and one battery will
last you a few hours,
and you can charge that a
couple times a day, I mean,
you can get seasons of
riding in literally weeks.
So, yeah, we were really happy
to see that it was actually
improving people's riding.
And when we were in New York,
we actually had somebody.
There was this [INAUDIBLE]
called us up and said,
hey, I've got to be at
this snowboarding mountain
to kind of do a customer
meeting and ride with them,
and I don't know
how to snowboard.
If I buy your board, can I
get up to speed and learn?
And I was, like,
yeah, I think so.
And we actually connected him
with one of our pro riders
in New York to kind
of show him the ropes,
and I love to close
a deal, but I'm--
but he was super happy
and actually rode.
So, yeah, it can definitely
get you into the sport.
AUDIENCE: So when
you ali, do you
try to land on the front
wheels because if you
land on the motors, it
might easily damage it.
AARON ADERS: Actually, all
the force bypasses the motors.
So you actually want
to land on your base.
AUDIENCE: OK, so flat.
AARON ADERS: Yeah, I mean a more
experienced rider can kind of
land on an edge or
something like that,
but landing flat is really
what you want to do,
and, yeah, you're coming
down on those casters.
But the way that the
mechanical system,
you might be able to tell,
if I could pause this,
it's an animated GIF.
But the motor is really
just kind of hanging off
a mount on the front.
And so all of that load is
going straight through the wheel
into the deck, and
you know, through you,
and then back down.
But it kind of
bypasses that motor.
Really, the motor is
just kind of hanging off.
And the only load on the motor
is the timing belt. So it's
built. I mean, we've
done seven stair gaps,
which is, you know,
maybe, yeah high.
And, yeah, it's
so funny, you just
have to like channel
that snowboarding
feeling and those mechanics.
If you approach like something
new, it's super scary.
But if you feel like,
oh, this is, you know,
just imagine the snow.
Like, channel your five-year-old
self and like see the snow,
it just magically works.
It's crazy.
AUDIENCE: OK, so when
you're dropping down
from seven stairs, do you land
like power slide or more like a
skateboard?
AARON ADERS: You can.
In fact, one of our riders,
his name is Slide Jump Slide.
He these slides, jumps,
and lands on a slide.
But, yeah, it's a super
challenging trick.
But, yeah, it's definitely.
I mean, that's like the great
thing about snowboarding,
and our board is like there's
this endless progression
and endless styles.
And so, yeah, you can land
sideways if you really want to.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool, thanks.
AARON ADERS: Oh, do we have?
OK.
AUDIENCE: You talk a little
bit about the-- your industrial
design process,
and you talk a lot
about wanting to mirror the
experience of snowboarding.
So how did you think
about that when
you were designing the board and
communicating the visual design
to a consumer that may not,
you know, have seen the video?
AARON ADERS: For sure, so for
us, you know, to call this--
I'm a snowboarder.
And if this didn't
feel like snowboarding,
I would have zero
interest in it.
And so in the beginning,
that's-- it's kind of how we
got our name.
So the Turing test of our
board was being able to--
like falling leaf
down the street.
So that's the first
move you learn on snow.
You're just kind of like a
falling leaf down the mountain.
And so our board had to do that.
Nothing else can falling
leaf down a city street.
And so we just kept iterating
and getting into where we
had enough torque to do that.
In the beginning, we were--
we were literally burning
the coils of the motors.
But it takes a lot of torque,
a powered caster wheel.
But in terms of the
industrial design,
honestly, for the
first version, you
can kind of tell the generation
of the person that designed it.
It kind of looks like
a first NES, or maybe
the first Playstation,
or something,
this real edgy, dark,
you know, device.
But I think that, you know,
when you see it, and--
and this-- this thing
popping out of the middle.
I mean, obviously, you're not
going to put your feet there,
but you know, your feet
are-- you kind of have
like a notion of-- of kind
of how to stand on it,
just-- just naturally where
that grip tape is and things.
But, yeah, I think
with future versions,
it can be a little bit
maybe more communicated
like a snowboard.
Also, you can't really tell
in this photo, but there's--
it's just bi-directional.
There's technically
no front to the board.
We do have some traction
control for beginners.
So we're sensing which
direction the board's
going and applying
power relative
to that, that direction.
So if you-- you
know, if you switch,
won't have like
anti-traction control.
It's got to-- it's got
to follow with you,
if you go the other way.
And I think that
kind of helps too,
because when they
get out the box, so,
you know, which way is forward?
But it doesn't matter.
It just, it knows
which way is forward?
But I I think there's--
yeah, definitely design wise,
we can pick up a lot
more in the next version.
AUDIENCE: And one
other unrelated
question you mentioned that
you started up in New York
and this genre of
product immediately
made me think of
Casey Neistat, who
is a very popular YouTuber
that's always messing around
with electric, you know,
modes of transportation.
Has he tried this yet?
AARON ADERS: You
know, it's funny.
We-- I don't think
he's tried it.
We actually ran into him
when we were beta testing.
It was like 10 degrees
January, New York.
And there was nobody out
except one of our beta riders.
It was actually my brother.
And he was testing along--
I don't if you've
been to New York,
but there's like
the Freedom Tower,
and there's this huge bike lane.
It's really nice and smooth.
And if it's 10 degrees
out, nobody's on it.
So he was out there going,
and Casey was actually--
you know how he rides his
board and films himself,
and he came up on our beta
rider, and, of course,
like, he threw this huge slide.
It was like, whoa!
What is that?
And he stopped him,
and he actually put us
on his daily blog that day.
And, yeah, our site
was just like--
I mean, it was like 12,000
visitors in the first,
you know, 20 minutes
after he posted that.
And all he did was just--
luckily, my brother had like
one of our promo cards on him
and just floated that out there,
and we had a ton of traffic.
And he's a big
snowboarder, and he
does this like
street snowboarding
thing where he takes like a--
I don't know.
I think it's like a water
ski rope behind a car
and snowboards around.
So this is like a lot
better for that than that.
But, yeah, he's kind
of the perfect person.
I know that he's really
involved with Boosted.
So I'm not sure if he has
much interest, but maybe.
AUDIENCE: So you said something
about traction control,
and I was wondering if
you could say a few things
about the hardware that's
inside kind of controlling
the motors a little bit?
AARON ADERS: Yeah, totally.
So the traction control
is remarkably symbol.
Basically, you know, when
you're going on to turn a car,
and you start to slide
out, then you, you know,
slow down those back wheels,
and kind of, you know,
lessens that slide
out a little bit.
And so what we do is basically
the same exact thing.
We're just slowing
down the back wheel.
But, again, without
being a front end,
the back can kind of change.
And so all, basically,
we have just a set
of positive magnets on one side
instead of negative magnets
on the other, Hall
sensor, and, you know,
if it's a positive reading,
we know we're going this way.
If it's negative reading, we
know we're going that way.
And then if that
changes, you just
change the power
going to each motor.
It happens in milliseconds.
And it's remarkably simple.
I just like literally
one Hall sensor,
and I, actually, there's like
an organization around Hall
sensors and MEMS and sensors.
And they found out somehow
we're using that, and I went,
and I did a presentation at
one of their conferences.
And they were super
excited until they
find I only had one Hall
sensor in the board,
and they were I think
a little disappointed.
They wanted to buy
more because there
are people with MRI machines
with thousands of Hall sensors.
And so, yeah, that was kind
of unexpected and funny.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I
was just wondering,
have you guys thought at
all about maybe this product
in the context of how like
a skate park might evolve?
And, specifically, I'm thinking
about how skate jumps are very
different, like,
it's a very different
than like a proper snowboard
kicker, you know, the landing,
and how that works, and
is there any thought of,
like, would this
kind of a product
work in that kind
of environment,
not just in like, you know,
hitting stair gaps and rails,
but also more
snowboard-style jumps?
AARON ADERS: Yeah, definitely.
So have you ever
heard of a pump track?
So it's like these--
this little track
that's got these bumps.
And if you're on
a skateboard, you
can kind of like pump and
keep momentum going around.
We thought those would
be great, but the scale
was just far too small.
It was, you know, built
for a little skateboard.
And with snowboarding,
you know, you've
got these massive runs
that are like, you know,
sometimes 10 lanes wide and,
you know, carving across those,
I mean, it's just-- you know,
it makes your whole day.
And so there is definitely
like a larger scale that
needs to happen with that, and
with the skate park, for me,
I like more like flat
transition, so maybe more
like a pyramid rather
than like a quarter pipe.
I do find that curve,
at least for me,
maybe my skills
aren't good enough.
But it kind of freaks me out.
And, you know, I've never really
tried that on a snowboard,
so I couldn't really tell you.
But what I do want
to know, and what
I love doing on this board is
more like, what would be great
is like a pyramid that
would be like the size
of this room with huge
walls that, you know,
kind of transition.
Those are super fun.
And I think that
definitely someday there
will be kind of a
park meant for these,
but I think it's going to be at
a much larger scale just given
kind of how snowboarding works
and the fun parts of that.
Yeah, and on that
note, actually, we--
you know, Prospect
Park in Brooklyn,
I don't know if anybody's
ever been there,
but it's like a LEIF resort.
It's incredible.
There is a huge loop
around the park that's
like four to six lanes
wide that's super fun
to carve and get up to speed.
But then there's all these
little paths in the middle.
And so it's a very
different experience,
you know, traveling
through these little paths
and going on the big outer ring.
But, you know, that's
kind of fun to kind
of experience with that.
But when we came to Los
Angeles, and, you know,
we rode up Griffith Park, which
is one of our favorite runs.
I mean, that was an even--
I'd never like used
the same product
and had such a
different experience,
you know, being on literally
the side of a mountain
going up that hill
to Griffith Park.
And so it's-- it
just blew our minds.
It was way different.
And I think there's just
so many different contexts
you can enjoy this board.
But I think that bigger,
wider is really nice.
AUDIENCE: How easy is it to
bring the board on a plane?
AARON ADERS: Yeah so we--
we designed the
batteries so that they're
compliant with TSA regulations.
And so I usually
carry on the board.
You always have to
carry on the battery,
and the remote controls,
there's a battery inside.
You can check the
board if you like.
I've actually carried
on two boards.
They were super annoyed, but
they let me through with it.
And, yeah, it just
fits in the overhead.
And a lot of our customers
take them everywhere,
and that was, you know, a key
feature we really had to have.
And that's why you see our
battery packs are actually
two batteries because to stay
under the watt hour limit,
we had to split the pack.
And we can get a
lot more mileage
and stay under that limit.
Everybody read ride?
Cool, let's do it.
[APPLAUSE]
Appreciate it.